I want to share some receipts with you.
It is sad
that it takes
a liberal atheist Turkish
reporter
to share with you what's happening with
the Christians in Lebanon
and what's happening with Armenian
Christians in Lebanon
because you don't hear that on the
Christian channels.
You don't hear that on the news and you
won't hear it from
David Wood or Apostate Prophet.
But you'll hear the latest attack
on
Tucker Carlson
you know, Candace Owens and the rest.
What do I mean?
It is sad.
That's why you don't throw out the baby
with the bathwater.
>> [clears throat]
>> You learn from everyone, even those you
don't agree with, even those who are
wrong, even unbelievers cuz they can
teach you something. All truth is God's
truth, so I watch.
But it's sad
that I had to learn this from Cenk Uygur
or Chunky Yogurt.
What is happening right now in Lebanon,
what Israel is doing to the Christians
and Christian villages, and how many
Christians
including Armenians are being
But you're not going to hear it. Now,
watch here.
So, I want to bring you the facts. It is
sad.
Let me hear. We don't need this here.
Very sad.
24 minute 24 second mark.
Watch here. I want you to listen to
this. Armenian Christians
Lebanese Christians, listen.
He just shared this today. Listen to
this, guys. Christian militias have now
joined Hezbollah to fight back against
Israel. Propaganda on their behalf. All
right, congratulations, Pat. I hope
you're proud. By the way, Israelis are
Armenians in Lebanon right now. Armenian
Christians? Send me the link. Go ahead,
Cenk.
Go ahead, Jake Tapper. Call the Armenian
Christians terrorists
for defending themselves against the
genocide.
I can't wait.
You know,
that's why they
notice on cable news, they never mention
the Christians. Never. As if there are
no Christians in the Middle East, right?
Cuz they're Here it.
They He's an atheist. He's mocked the
Bible.
He doesn't believe in God.
>> [clears throat]
>> Turkish atheist
mocks the Bible. He doesn't believe in
God.
Listen to this again.
Propaganda on their behalf. All right,
congratulations, Pat. I hope you're
proud. By the way, Israelis are
Armenians in Lebanon right now. Armenian
Christians?
Go ahead, Jake.
Go ahead, Jake Tapper. Call the Armenian
Christians terrorists
for defending themselves against the
genocide.
I can't wait.
You know,
that's why they
notice on cable news, they never mention
the Christians. Never. By the way,
David, you're the second person. Julio
just said it, too. IDF soldier smashed
the statue of Jesus. Send me the link so
I can share it on the screen.
Both David on Rumble and Julio here on
YouTube said the same thing.
IDF soldier smashes a statue of Jesus.
Never. As if there are no Christians in
the Middle East, right? Cuz they're
like, "Oh, Muslims, dirty savage
terrorists. Israel, angelic victims."
Christians
Well, I mean, they have to Muslims. They
have to It's not Israel's fault. They
They were forced to Muslims to take
their land. I mean, I mean, I mean, I
mean, it's for self-defense. But when
you say they were forced to
Christians and take their land for
self-defense
it lands a little differently here in
America. And they all know that. That's
why every liar and propagandist on cable
news never mentions the Christians being
by Israel. You see that?
It took
an atheist
to tell you
our Christian brothers and sisters,
those who love the Lord Jesus Christ,
are being
by Israel soldiers. Their villages being
churches being destroyed.
It took an atheist to tell you this.
An atheist.
So, is this the word Elshonai show that
he destroyed a statue of Jesus, brother?
Cuz you sent me a link Israel tears down
statue. Okay. Christian saint, but they
said, "No, IDF destroys a statue of
Jesus." But I'll share this as well.
It says Saint George, brother.
I went there and I clicked on it. Says
Saint George, not a statue of Jesus.
Saint George. But nonetheless
All right, let me hold on. Let me go
there. Too many of you. I can't keep up
with you. I got to go to my Hold on. 1
second. The brother just shared it. I
want to show these. Okay.
Okay, but where is the statue, man? You
guys are sending me links. I don't see
them smashing statues.
All right. So, Jeremy, you sent me
Pro-Life Chloe's post. Where is the
destruction? Oh, I see now. I get it. I
see. I get it. I got it now. I thank
you. I saw now.
All right. Anyway
Anyway, I want to make a challenge
to David Wood and Apostate Prophet. You
guys can say I called them out. So, they
can do another 4-hour
piece and try and defame me so they can
expose that they're dogs and bastards of
Satan. They're not Christian.
I'm going to pay their expenses. I
promise you. I'll take money from my
savings
that I'm saving for my daughters.
I will pay for their flight and hotel
if they go to New York or some other
place with a large Jewish population
record them preaching the gospel to
Orthodox Jews and standing outside of
synagogues and trying to
preach the gospel of Jesus Christ to
them and pass out tracts.
Okay?
And how the Armenian Christian militias
have now joined Hezbollah to fight back
against Israel. You see what Israel did?
The Armenian Christians, the freedom
fighters, now are driven to join the
side of Hezbollah to attack Israel. So,
now guess what Apostate Prophet's going
to do. He's going to say, "You see?
These Christians are helping the
terrorist
to try to destroy Israel."
Not that Netanyahu went into Lebanon and
annexed lands
Christian villages. In the process,
priests get children get
elderly get killed and churches get
bombed.
See that?
You got it, right?
Okay, did you know they were
slaughtering Christians in Lebanon? No,
cuz our main national media doesn't do
news. They cover up the news. Hear it?
An atheist has to tell you, "Did you
know they're slaughtering Christians in
Lebanon?" No, I didn't know. Meaning, I
knew what they were doing to Chris but I
didn't know
that there Armenians now who are now
joining to fight against Israel for
murdering Christians. I didn't know
that. Did you? Here it is, one more
time.
Christian militias have now joined
Hezbollah to fight back against Israel.
Okay, did you know they were
slaughtering Christians in Lebanon? No,
cuz our main national media doesn't do
news. They cover up the news. All right,
couple more then I got to No. Here's the
image.
Pro-Life Chloe, thank you. Here's the
Okay, let's go here.
There you go. And okay, well, let's Let
me just open up a few more. All right.
Yep, thank you. We got two of them.
Thank you, brother.
So, let's go here.
There you go.
What When is it enough? IDF soldier in a
Christian [clears throat] village in
Lebanon
show what they think of my Lord and God.
Yet Christian Zionist call them God's
chosen people. They're showing you what
they think of Christ and you're still
being their dummies.
There you go.
He's doing what his ancestors did to
Jesus.
The same blood of his ancestors is
running in his veins
because it was his ancestors,
those Jews who rejected Jesus, that
their God in the flesh.
And that's New Testament teaching.
Here it is. That's Pro-Life Chloe. God
bless her. I didn't even know. Here it
is on Twitter. Thank you, Jesus Christ
reigns.
Thank you.
Let me see something. Let me say it now.
1 second.
I just wanted to send this out. Make,
you know, make him happy.
All right. So just wanted to
get them to do another 10-hour stream
trying to
defame me cuz they can't refute me.
An image approvingly shared by an
Israeli soldier shows a statue of Jesus
Christ
in South Lebanon being struck with a
mallet by a member of the Israeli
occupation forces.
So, what do we say about this, my
brothers and sisters?
Yeah, apostate prophet and David Wood
are two Zionist They sold out.
David takes money from a pro-Israeli
company. I'm going to show it to you.
So, yeah, he he sold out. He's not a
Christian.
Now, I can only judge them by their
fruits.
I don't have access to their hearts.
Their fruits tell me they're not
Christians.